move over jupiter ascending there's a
new jupiter in town
create life netflix's latest superhero
original starring that guy from all my
children leaves a lot of unanswered
questions so in this video we'll be
taking a deep dive into the season
its connections to the comics and
theories for season two
so grab your blue rod and make sure to
like and subscribe seriously 91
of you aren't subscribed you begged me
to do it
because here we go welcome to supermax
which is basically jupiter's legacy's
version of the raft a maximum security
prison where supervillains put away by
the union go to live out their days
over the course of the season we get to
see two such villains who were put away
here the first being jack hobbs a
criminal mastermind who also
acts as sheldon sampson's aka utopia's
therapist it's clear throughout the
season that sheldon has a lot of
emotional baggage and
who better to unload that onto than a
man who can't leave his cell
in the comics jack ends up creating a
weapon that can take away a hero's
powers and bestow them upon himself
and his henchmen but with him still
locked up we don't know if this will be
a storyline in the future the second
supervillain who plays a far more
prominent role than jack is
black star in episode 1 if you listen
carefully and read the closed captions
you'll learn that black star used to be
a scientist by the name of william henry
bendel he has an anti-matter battery
buried in his chest but the show doesn't
go into detail into black star's origin
story
we do know however that he has several
criminal followers like
baryon who we see take on lady liberty
in episode 6.
for an evil villain he sure has a love
for romance novels like forbidden touch
or
faithless seduction which is written by
fictitious author fiona bauer who is the
show's art department coordinator to his
surprise black star's cell door opens
allowing him to escape
in episode 7 we saw walter sampson aka
brainwave
visit blackstar with the real intention
of disabling the lock on his cell
door as we'll find out later this is all
part of walt's master plan which makes
the dialogue in this scene all the more
powerful
knowing walt will eventually betray his
brother if i could
i'd find a way to expose utopian for the
fraud that he
that's exactly what walt wants he wants
to show how the utopians code the rule
members of the union live by
is flawed and outdated he secretly
despises his brother
i don't give a [ __ ] i'm not my
brother and walt definitely is not he
has a completely different philosophical
belief on how members of the union
should use their powers walt believes
that the union should intervene and
shape world events
even if it means killing he even says in
the final episode
why did they give us these powers at all
so we could rule the world
obviously take for example sheldon and
walt's discussion of whether or not they
should have intervened in world war
ii sheldon says such an intervention
goes against the code
it is against the code we don't kill
we don't lead we inspire if they were to
intervene it would be taking away
free will from the rest of humanity
which walt responds
well some would say free will
is what's bringing the world to his
knees this foreshadows what happens in
the comics when walt ends up turning the
union against the utopian and leading
the world into a dystopian future where
he rules all
but walt's motivation for believing this
particular worldview is rooted in his
jealousy and resentment for his brother
walt hated how sheldon was their
father's golden child who could do no
wrong
what my problem is it's taking a
backseat to a younger brother
never deserved half the attention he
received this harkens back to the year
1929 when walt insisted their father not
expand the company's steel mill
fearing an economic collapse the father
however listened to
sheldon and the company eventually lost
everything in the great depression
the dad would still be alive if you
listen to me
if walt had intervened maybe his father
would still be alive
this is what drives his philosophical
belief and deep-rooted hatred for his
brother and everything he stands for
throughout the show we travel back in
time to see how the original members of
the union acquired their powers
you'll notice how the aspect ratio
changes during these scenes to full
screen which is closer to what you'd get
in the 1930s
in episode 7 we saw how sheldon's
visions led him and a crew of five
others to a mysterious island in the
atlantic here they'll undergo a series
of challenges that test their character
challenges that previous travelers
failed the crew remarks on finding maori
clothing and viking armor some thing
some power has been calling humanity
toward it for centuries
the show is called jupiter's legacy
because it's a moon of jupiter where the
heroes eventually get their power
not explained however is why and whom is
in charge of dispensing this power
we don't even get an answer as to how
some characters have powers and others
do not we do know that the original
six can pass on part or all or none of
their powers to their children
we see this in the very first episode
with chloe and brandon as kids
but there are several other characters
who weren't on the island and as far as
we know
aren't related to the original six and
they have powers for example
nick of time barnabas wolf or iron
orchid
one theory out there is that the power
that washed over the island and beyond
somehow unlocked powers to the ship's
crew or possibly beyond when that power
or
energy does wash past them we see their
faces light up with these same patterns
found on the island's trees and rocks
some of the union's children do not
possess any powers most notably hutch
the son of george hutchins aka
skyfox in the comics this power rod was
built by george and given to his son
since he felt sorry he didn't have any
powers
in the show however the rod is given to
richard conrad aka blue bolt by the
island we never see blue bolt in the
present day hinting that he's either
dead or in hiding but since he has lost
this rod and now it's in the hands of
hutch
it's likely george had something to do
with this speaking of george the show
never goes into how he went from
sheldon's best friend and valiant member
of the union to the world's greatest
supervillain
in the comics george proposes to a girl
named sunny but is turned down because
she thinks he's too immature
and a playboy that could be why when
hutch asks the rod to send him to his
dad it always leads him to a strip club
a cheeky nod to his father's
philandering past in episode 8 we even
see an article which says
skyfox saving the world getting the
girls sunny ends up falling in love with
walter and george
can't take it he decides to live
incognito but he'll later learn that
walter was using his psychic powers on
sonny to make her fall in love with him
which of course
george does not like now there is a
sunny credited in episode one
she's the girl we see for a brief moment
in that fake world walt crates which he
uses to hold off the black star clone
either this is just a coincidence or
walt conjured her in this scenario from
a memory of his past
around the same time george becomes
disillusioned with the world he's helped
keep in balance particularly u.s
hegemony back in the day the world was
black and white you had the allies
versus the axes good versus bad but now
the world isn't so clear-cut
george ends up taking vice president
hubert humphrey hostage refusing to
release him until president lyndon
johnson ends the vietnam war
george believes he and the other heroes
have been nothing but pawns in an
establishment that undermines the
working class hence his eventual parting
with the union it's both philosophical
moral and personal what exactly happens
after this event is unknown just that
the union has been unsuccessful in
tracking george down
but the person who may hold a clue to
his whereabouts is his own
son throughout the course of the season
we see hutch building some sort of
device he steals a power core from china
which coincidentally or not
is the same color as the light that
washed over the island
he believes this machine can take him to
his father it incorporates the rod so
it's possible it could be a machine that
can take him through time
or through alternate dimensions this is
where george will be
it's also possible considering george's
past with walt that george could be
somewhere out there but lost his memory
we know that walt has the ability to
delete memories so that may come into
play if there's a season two back in
time we learned that some of the members
of the union
initially kept their identity secret by
wearing mass we get this shot of grace
aka lady liberty lifting up a car which
her daughter chloe will later recreate
for a photo shoot
in present day walt has ventured into
the mind of the black star clone
walt was the one who created this clone
in the first place not
george this is all part of his master
plan later lady liberty will venture in
to save well but this is all part of his
plan too
using his psychic powers he's created an
image of george to send a message
an image of george over the dead bodies
of sheldon and brandon an image which he
says will happen in the future
it's a warning here is where it can get
a bit confusing
this image here seems to be completely
fabricated by walt however this sky fox
we see in blackstar's mind
could and likely is the real skyfox who
was lured there by
walt it's unlikely though that he was
trapped within this clone's mind for
decades and his real whereabouts are
still
unknown it might also be possible this
entire thing was an act by walt but
that doesn't seem as likely meanwhile
hutch's crew finds out he's been
sleeping with chloe the daughter of the
utopian
they won't help him steal the power core
in china because of the risk of getting
in a tussle with the world's strongest
superhero
fun fact the getaway van they purchased
which can go through walls
was sold by hatto the sorcerer a
character from the league of
extraordinary gentlemen comics who is
based off real-life occultist alastair
crowley it's chloe who ends up saving
hutch from the chinese vault after he
decides to go at it alone
she's been following him and in this
scene we get to see that bullets bounce
right off her and she also speaks
mandarin her saving of hutch also allows
him to open up to her
and show off what he's been working on a
device she thinks may be used to kill
her dad
after all the man who helped design a
part of it says what is in this case
could power a small city for a year
or punch a hole through the mightiest
being on the planet
in the comics chloe and hutch end up
joining forces in a dystopian future
where walt has taken over and the
utopian has been killed
at the super mex brandon and his father
the utopian take on the real black star
ultimately putting the utopian in his
biggest moral dilemma kill black star
and save his son but
break the code or uphold the code and
lose his son
and it takes a while for the utopian to
make this decision a decision which
never happens because
petra comes in and saves the day brandon
eventually gains control of the
situation
and in a reverse from the events of
episode 1 decides to uphold the code and
not
kill blackstar it's heavily implied
brandon believes his father was going to
let him die
that his father believes more in the
code than his own
son this sets him up perfectly for
season 2 to later join walt
i will mention that just before petra
saves the day we do see the utopian's
eyes flash blue for a quick second
hinting that he was in fact
going to kill blackstar but we'll just
never know
we get one final flashback of the union
coming into their headquarters for the
first time
notice how fitz can walk here in the
comics he loses his ability to walk
after a battle but considering the
amount of changes the show has made from
the original material
i wouldn't be surprised if this injury
in the show will somehow
tie back into george finally we have
raiku walt's daughter who helps her
father get into blackstar's head but in
so doing finds out his plan
she and him don't have the best
relationship with her having resentment
for how he left her mother
she even blackmails him for 50 million
dollars threatening to expose him if she
doesn't get the money
but walt so believes he's doing the
right thing that he ends up
killing his own daughter this is
juxtaposed with him consoling sheldon
who believes he's about to lose his
child after failing to protect him
against black star we have one father
who killed this child and the other who
fears
losing a child for walt this is all
going according to plan he's caused a
rift between the utopian and his son
utopian and the rest of the heroes and
simultaneously set up george as the fake
villain
if all goes according to plan it looks
like the show will follow in the
footsteps of the comic
with season 2 focusing on the fracturing
of the union and the death of the
utopian with walt coming into power and
taking over the world
but what did you think of jupiter's
legacy do you think it will get a season
2 renewal
let me know in the comments below thanks
for watching and be sure to like and
subscribe it really helps the channel
out a lot